in this video I want to talk about
eukaryotic regulation of gene expression
so in eukaryotes gene expression can be
regulated in a variety of ways so those
three ways that I'm going to talk about
are transcriptional regulation post
transcriptional regulation and post
translational modifications so
transcript transcriptional regulation
involves controlling RNA polymerase
activity so RNA polymerase carries out
transcription so if we control or
regulate how that RNA polymerase is
working how how much is it working how
often is it working so basically how
much of a certain gene is transcribed
because if more if the diff a gene is
transcribed more that means we'll be W
be more I'm RNA or mRNA means more
protein product so this involves if
we're if we're controlling RNA
polymerase activity it involves of
course basal transcription factors which
are the transcription factors that have
to show up at all the promoters so this
includes transcription factors that
we've talked about D and he fab there
are also these things called specific
transcription factors and these only
exist for certain genes and for certain
genes they might have a different
transcription factor than another gene
so maybe gene 1 requires this
transcription factor but gene 10 you
know requires a different transcription
factor but they would both require all
the same basal transcription factors so
the next thing is post transcriptional
regulation of mRNA so mRNA once once
it's made it can be modified via this
process called alternative splicing and
I actually want to write that in hot
pink because I want it to be an
important idea alternative splicing is
actually something we'll talk about in a
later video so alternative splicing or
alternative processing is another way
that it's known this is the idea that
the same mRNA sequence can be spliced in
a variety of ways another
post-transcriptional form of regulation
is that mrna once it's after it's been
transcribed it needs to go from the
nucleus in eukaryotes from the nucleus
to the cytoplasm in order to be
translated so if if it's controlled how
much and how often the transcribed mRNA
is being sent to the cytoplasm that sort
of regulates how much will eventually be
translated another thing a
post-transcriptional modification or
submit a post transcriptional form of
regulation is the stability of the mRNA
in the cytoplasm
so once the mRNA is even at the
cytoplasm how much of it is actually
going to be translated before it's
degraded so there are nucleases all over
the place right if these nucleases get
to it quickly like what is it that is
going to protect this mRNA right
if the mRNA lasts longer than the
cytoplasm more of it will be translated
if it doesn't last as long in the
cytoplasm it not not as much would be
translated so those are all happening
after transcription is finished the last
thing is post translational modification
and this usually involves protease
activity which oops not pre protease
protease activity a protease is an
enzyme that cuts proteins so after an
mRNA has been translated and you have a
particular polypeptide chain it can be
cleaved by a protease so generally
speaking what protease is do is when
they do cut proteins they take them from
inactive precursors and turn them into
active proteins the inactive precursors
are usually called zymogens and they
usually end in Ojin but an example that
i came up with is or that i didn't
really come up with it but it's one of
the examples is that insulin is an
active peptide hormone so it has
precursors that
called pre-pro insulin and that's
actually cleaved via protease and it
turns into insulin and then there's
further protease activity that cuts it
and turns it into insulin I actually
have another video on that and enzyme
regulation so check that video out if
you want more details on this
another example is chymotrypsinogen kymo
trypsin no Jin which is a digestive
enzyme this needs to be cleaved and
turned into chymotrypsin which is the
active protein so these these post
translational modifications basically
tell you like if if these proteins came
from a certain gene then how often we
turn these inactive precursors into the
active active proteins is a form of
regulating exactly how it's being
expressed
I hope that video was helpful in a sort
of overview kind of fashion it was a
bunch of words so I might have been
boring and I apologize for that but I
hope that was helpful I am a tutor if
you live in Southern California feel
free to contact me via email at MU for
University ID gmail.com see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching